everyone at this point is kind of on
their own making ready for being able to
reuse especially masks but also things
like gowns and plastic sheets to be able
to keep our barriers when we're doing
difficult procedures with patients
doctors around the country such as
Denver based ER dr. case Newsome are
running dangerously low on the n95 mask
which protocol says they should wear and
then dispose of every time they walk out
of an infected patients room so they're
reusing the same masks repeatedly my
colleagues are busy at work creating UV
decontamination ovens on their own
because those are expensive and
difficult to come by but easy enough to
produce several of them have in fact
learned how to sew so they can make
their own masks if we run fully out the
federal government estimates that
medical professionals will need 3.5
billion masks if the most dire
projections are borne out the u.s. had
about 1% of that number on hand at the
beginning of march charities and major
corporations have donated masks
hospitals and manufacturers like
Honeywell and 3m have stepped up
production New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo has asked President Trump to use
the defense production act to force
companies to start making masks and yet
official channels likely won't come
close to meeting the needs of health
care workers so some technologists are
taking matters into their own hands but
will government officials adhere to
existing regulations and slow down these
efforts and if we could manufacture
enough masks for the entire population
would it be possible to hasten the end
of the extreme social distancing
crippling our economy we are a group of
engineers entrepreneurs and problem
solvers focused on prototyping and
manufacturing and 95 masks domestically
Matt Chisholm is a spokesperson for the
open PPE project which is developing a
protocol for production of n95 grade
masks which experts believe provide
fairly reliable protection against kovat
19 they're planning to open their own
Factory in Michigan and to develop a
manufacturing blueprint that anyone can
use masks don't seem like they would be
a extremely complicated product to
manufacture so what have the biggest and
most surprising challenge has been so
far in undertaking this one regulatory
of the regulatory state
some of the materials in the beginning
it just took some time to find the right
sources for them one of the biggest
inputs into our mask is a material
called melt loan polypropylene but we
have identified someone who can provide
that to us surgical masks require FDA
approval though the agency relaxed its
guidelines in late March the National
Institute of Occupational Safety and
Health a division of the CDC regulates
filtration masks factories
according to Chisolm and official with
the agency told his team that it will
take 45 to 90 days to get approval for a
new mask production facility that poses
some challenges for the current crisis
were in you could theoretically end up
with 45 to 90 days worth of supplies
that are in a warehouse instead of out
on the front line saving lives one thing
we've recommended is that we allow
universities who have the capabilities
to do testing on masks to at minimum
maybe be involved in this process to
give the give the approval on some of
these and 95 masks and other personal
protective equipment meanwhile 3d
printing enthusiasts are sidestepping
regulatory approval by teaching people
how to make their own masks the DIY mask
approach has taken off in the Czech
Republic in particular where surgical
masks sewing efforts are being
coordinated over the Internet by
providing instructions tips and mapping
facilities in areas where masks are most
needed the CDC is stating that we're to
be using bandanas if it comes down to it
I think I would certainly trust the
capacity of any physician or nurse to be
able to at least visibly and inspect the
quality of the material that they've
been given to be better than a single
ply t-shirt or cloth fiber I understand
that it's not a perfect solution but
that being said anything I think would
be better than the sort of last resort
of people having to formulate their own
how difficult would it be for doctors
who still would prefer something like
that to a bandana to bring that into a
hospital to protect themselves would the
hospital you know stop them at the door
and say you know no unauthorised masks
or would it still potentially be of
service it's really hard to question if
if they're bringing in something that
they've done their research on to know
that it's an adequate level of
protection ma'am you cannot look at
every single person's practices at
keeping themselves clean and not
infecting people so the fact that
they're effectively already running out
actually lends a little bit of an
opportunity for these sort of I guess
you could call it like guerilla industry
actors to come in with new novel devices
some say that ubiquitous mask-wearing
could make it safe to end extreme social
distancing but public health agencies
have issued conflicting information
about their efficacy if you do not have
any respiratory symptoms such as fever
cough or runny nose you do not need to
wear a medical mask like this one mask
alone can give you a false feeling of
protection and can even be a source of
infection we're not used correctly on
February 29th the US Surgeon General
urged the public to stop buying masks
claiming they're ineffective in stopping
the transmission of kovat 19 and could
even increase one's likelihood of
catching it the CDC and w-h-o have
recommended masks wearing only for those
in direct contact with infected
individuals but critics say this is
inaccurate and that public health
officials may have purposely spread
misinformation to discourage a run on
masks making it even harder for doctors
nurses and first responders to obtain
them mask wearing is widespread in Hong
Kong and Taiwan which seems to have
controlled kovat 19 without prolonged
lock downs Hong Kong public health
officials have called for masks wearing
on public transit and in the workplace
there's evidence that masks help stop
the spread of the flu and those strong
evidence that face masks prevent
respiratory infections is still scarce
due to a lack of rigorous study
according to a March 2020 paper
published in The Lancet there is a
chance that community transmission might
be reduced if everyone wear face masks
Oxford researcher Alain Fong co-authored
that paper we should prioritize that
health care workers first but I don't
think this should be the rationale to
tell the public that face mask is not
effective we highlighted the distinction
between the absence of evidence and
evidence of absence
how would you
in that case a universal facemask policy
for coronavirus there's some evidence
showing that people who have been
infected but have not had the symptom
onset could transmit the virus to others
without even knowing that in Asian
countries it's more likely to be a civic
duty for the people to wear the facemask
we think the universal face much policy
during the pandemic could help to
prevent these segments ization
on people who are aware defacements if
the supply permits probably not a place
to speculate on the role NASA will play
beyond medical personnel after we beat
Koba 19 I'm not sure what the demands
going to look like for mess I assume
that will might be more people who wear
them when they're sick we weren't
prepared for this we need to get back to
good and make sure we can arm our
frontline personnel with equipment we
need we also have to be ready for what
any pandemic in the future could could
bring and manufacturing readiness could
really help that and Newsom asks that
anyone with extra n95 masks or other
essential medical gear donate them to
medical professionals to help adjust to
this new reality it's the nature of our
work that we are touching patients that
have respiratory problems and we really
would benefit from those masks I'm
literally witnessing colleagues of mine
learning how to hunker down and like do
protective measures I mean that I didn't
learn any of that in my residency you
know how to decontaminate your own masks
and stuff the fact that this is all
happening point-of-care when the need
arises goes to show the level of
unpreparedness